there was a mathematician named Klein
who thought Mobius bands are divine said
he if you glue the edges of two you get
the weird bottle like mine
you're probably familiar with a Mobius
band it's the special shape where if you
run your finger on the surface you start
here on the outside you're running it
along the surface and magically you're
ending up on the other side so if you
have been able to go from one side of
the surface to the other without
actually stepping over the edge we just
did it by going once around the loop so
if you were to start spreading paint
from here and we just paint and paint
and paint that surface they'll actually
end up painting everything and so this
is called a single sided surface or
mathematicians also call it and
non-orientable surface just one face one
paint color needed to paint everything
now this particular surface has an edge
so here is an edge let's see if we go
along this particular edge I'm running
around here I'm going through my hand
I'm on the bottom side now and I'm going
through the bottom of the edge and
suddenly come back up again so it's only
a single edge but the edge Haseley goes
twice around that loop so we have a
single sided surface with a single edge
now the single sided surface is pretty
intriguing we got from one side of the
surface to the other without having to
drill through the surface or without
having to step across the edge is it
possible to make a single sided surface
that has no edges that's kind of closed
just like a sphere has no edges right
it's a closed surface but in a sphere to
get from the inside to the outside
you clearly have to drill through the
surface so can we make a single sided
surface that has no edges that you could
step over and where it seems impossible
to get from one side to the other you
can it's called a Klein bottle this is a
client bottle now how this is what we
said before apply is this really single
sided assume that you're an end and now
the end is walking on the outside of the
bulb and getting to the outside of the
handle walking around the outside of the
handle walking on the outside of the
handle and penetrating through the wall
but staying on the outside of the
handle on this inner part and you now if
you imagine that you're on the outside
of this inner handle you're now inside
this bulb so as you walk around the
bottom you're still on the inside you
can walk all around the inside of this
bulb you can then continue on the inside
of the bulb walking into the inside of
the handle now you're walking on the
inside of the tunnel all the way around
the loop you're staying on the inside of
the handle and you're coming out and get
back on the outside again so it is
indeed possible to get from one side of
the glass surface to the other but
didn't you pass what you didn't drill a
hole but wouldn't you have needed to
drill a ha you caught me
okay unfortunately there are no Klein
bottles that have no so-called self
intersections the Klein bottle really is
a mathematical construct that you could
do in four dimensional space without any
intersections any kind of Klein bottle
that you want to do in three-dimensional
space does indeed have some kind of
penetration now the rules for
mathematicians is there are two surfaces
like that the branches go through one
another they're completely unaware and
oblivious that they're branching you're
basically allowed to stay on your
surface you cannot step from one to the
other but of course implicitly
as you go on this surface through the
other one you basically have gone from
one side to the other and that's why the
Klein bottle works in three dimensions
okay so in the rules of mathematics the
aunt doesn't need a drill to get through
it doesn't even know that there is this
other surface coming through it just
blocks basically on that surface and it
sees no no other surface except the one
that it's walking on and so that's how
it gets magically from one side to the
other so that is kind of the simplest
form of a Klein bottle it is made by
cliff Stoll of an ACME klein bottles in
Berkeley and he is an amazing amount of
different client bottles you can get
from him and I'll just go to his website
Acme Klein bottles and for instance you
know what the spine is the kind of thing
they have in the whorehouse at the
Oktoberfest there is your spine except
it's a small Stein but it's a special
Stein it's a klein stein if you look
closely down here you can see it seems
to have a double wall and indeed it does
have a double
so now if you pour a liquid up on top
inside and then you find that there's a
hole here that goes from the inner
volume into the handle and so by the
time the liquid reaches that little hole
and runs down the handle it will pour
into the interstitial space between the
inner and the outer cylinder and it fill
the outer space so you realize the
potential you basically fill in coffee
into the outside and you fill in brandy
on the inside and you're sitting happily
in your office and when your boss comes
by you severe that you're drinking
coffee but you're enjoying yourself very
much with what's on the inner part of it
so this is a client Stein topologically
it is exactly like this Klein bottle
just has a different shape you know
there's this extra bulb kind of stuffed
in but other than that it's exactly the
same deal you know you can walk
basically on one surface and then go
around the handle make this unofficial
kind of transition through the glass
surface and get essentially from one
side to the other
so still a client bottle it's still a
single sided surface that has no edges
per se so here is my client stein and we
want to see what happens when we pour a
liquid into it have a little bit of
coffee and we start to fill in and at
the beginning everything is normal and
nothing special happens so now so far
everything is just as it would be in an
ordinary stein but now as we pour in
more liquid see what happens when you
get to the handle oh no it starts to run
down the handle here okay so now we have
a trapped air volume up here right and
it's kind of hard to now fill it without
kind of you know shaking a little bit
and let's try and get the air bubbles
out so that's kind of a problem so maybe
we already feel too much so what we
should do is pour out a little bit more
and now that we have more flexibility
we can get so it's a little bit hard to
set up your your coffee cup on the
outside we send the brand you on the
inside as you as you can see but so
gradually we're getting a higher filling
level here on the outside a client
bottle is made from two mobius bands
remember a Mobius band is a single sided
surface but it has that one edge now if
you take two mobius bands a red one and
the green one and they both have just
one edge and now you're starting to fuse
those edges together and you kind of
zipper them along those edges right what
you get well all the edges have
disappeared it's like taking two disks
right and the two disks have two edges
you close the two disks together they
form a sphere but if you do that here
yes we get rid of all the edges but it's
still single sided because each piece
itself a single side in the first place
so we get a single sided surface that
has no edges actually we get a client
bottle here is something that also cliff
Stoll made well it looks sort of like a
client bottle so here is the bowels
right and here is that handle and here
is that kind of transition where the
handle essentially goes through that
surface and goes inside that bulb now
the beauty of this object is that
somewhere here is a zipper now if I can
find the beginning of the zipper there
it is so now we can open that zipper
that's like cutting the client bottle
into two parts so I'm ripping open to
have to go twice around the loop
remember that these loops here on the
Mobius band they go with twice around so
basically I have to zip twice around
here see now I'm coming on my second
pass here and then it falls apart oh my
god what have I got here
I have this band right and the band
somehow looks twist it and yes of course
it varies in width it starts out narrow
and it gets through the white part which
then forms the bulb but there's clearly
a twist of 180 degree right about here
so this is a Mobius band
and the other half is essentially its
mirror image so here again is a Mobius
band and we have seen the two together
essentially form the Klein bottle so
that shows how a Klein bottle is formed
from two Mobius Bands here again is an
ordinary-looking kind of klein bottle
okay I made the bulb a little narrower
and I put more emphasis basically on the
handle here and you can see that's the
place where the handle goes back into
the bulb I think that's kind of the way
yeah these two things look now if you
look at the handle you can see that the
the lines here in the handle are
essentially twisted so in glass you
cannot see that where it's twisted or
not but if you put this structure on
there you can actually give it a twist
I put the twist it off a full turn of
360 degrees and then I cut it apart
along a line not like the other Klein
bottle which I had split simply smack
down the similar plane but I essentially
cut it down along one of those twisted
spiral things and look what happens I
basically get two of those things
interlocking now and each one
individually is essentially a Mobius
band you can see it's as the band that
starts here it warps around and then it
makes it a 180 degree flip up here so
here's again is another way of
essentially turning a client bottle into
two mobius bands but because of the
twists that I put into the handle now
the two mobius bands are actually
intertwined so most people who have
heard about klein bottles probably have
seen a picture of that that's the most
familiar one but actually mathematician
tell you there's more than just one
klein bottle and this is also a klein
bottle at first glance it looks kind of
weird and jumbled down what's going on
well what's going on is that we make
ourselves a tube like we have here but
the tube now is not having a circular
cross-section
but we make ourselves a tube that has a
figure-eight cross-section like that and
you can see if we had to do that and you
color it then if you paint red on the
one half of this figure eight the thread
would go through that Junction and be on
the inside of the other loop and then
green would be on the outside here and
green would be on the other side so if
we take this to color tube and we flip
it around in a big circle and showing it
back to itself red goes to red green
goes to read green it still would be a
torus just an ordinary torus but if you
take this figure eight and we rotate it
180 degrees and then join it back to
itself well the red lobe joins us the
green lobe the green lobe Jones with the
red lobe and we have the same situation
we had before but if you start painting
and she's paint and paint before we know
it you have painted everything so we're
back to a single sided surface that's
exactly what we have here so if you
focus in on that part you can see
essentially this figure eight
cross-section which I mentioned before
and I very carefully made sure that
right here at the intersection line if
you look at the lines that come from one
side they're going through that
cross-section is out touching the other
ones again that confirms that
mathematical notion that there are two
surfaces cross you cannot step from one
to the other they're kind of oblivious
of one from the other okay so this is
our figure right cross section now we're
swinging this figure I have cross
section around the loop and while doing
so we must make sure we have an odd
number of flips we could get you know a
single flip from here going once around
a single handle a degree flip but in
this case I actually have elected to do
three flips so here it is in that
configuration it flips and here again
it's facing up to you it flips once more
to here and then once more to here so
three times 180 degree flip also make
sure that one of those lobes when you
come around you're on the other lobe and
that makes it into a single sided
surface and that again is a client
bottle there are no edges it's single
sided it happens to same kind of
connectivity as this particular client
bottle it seems very different from that
one
is quite different and particularly the
mathematicians in this case when you ask
them why are they differently they say
because there's no way that you can
smoothly transform this object into that
object they have a fancy name they call
something a regular homo topi if it is
possible to buy only smoothly deforming
thing never ever have any sharp creases
never ever doing this kind of thing
where you have a loop and then you just
can't get rid of that loop that's not
allowed as long as you smoothly deform
things no matter how much you stretch
and compress that's a regular homotopy
int two things are so equal or in the
same regular home up to the class if you
can transform them you cannot transform
that into this that's why these client
bottles are different now if you look at
this it has clearly a handedness to it
it's a rotates in this case I think if
you go forward it rotates of
counterclockwise as you as you kind of
smooth we go forward you can see that
cross-section rotating of a counter
clockwise okay
the mirror image of that is in a
different regular homotopy class you
cannot transform that into its mirror
image
the reason piece basically you cannot
take a Mobius band and smoothly
transform it into its mirror image it
has a handedness built-in right and
remember Cline bolts are built from two
mobius bands turns out the regular klein
bottle here is built from one
right-handed one left-handed Mobius band
we've seen that before we had those two
Mobius bands and when they fell apart
they were mirror images a right one and
the left one so here if you have
something that is a figure eight that
twists right hand it you cut it apart in
the middle it essentially composes into
two right-handed Mobius bands the other
one falls into two left-handed Mobius
bands okay so we already have three
different regular homotopy s4 client
bottles three different client bottles
well that was known in a paper going
back to about 30 years
and Hughes and they make one more
observation they say if you essentially
put a structure like this coordinate
great we have or some color on the
surface then there are four different
client bottles and that really intrigued
me so I I set out you know several
months of my life to think I want to
find that fourth client bottle now that
mathematical paper was above my horizon
I couldn't follow all these logics that
had to do is group theory and symmetry
observation and the like I want to make
a really nice picture figure out what's
going on here and in that process I came
up with other interesting client bottles
so here what is this well it's again a
figure 8 loop now it forms a trefoil
knot have you seen before actually it is
really no different from that one
because remember topologists allow you
to smoothly pass surfaces through one
another in particular and not makes no
sense to a topologist because you have
two strands and you know they pass right
through one another so you could open
this trefoil knot into just a simple
loop and it would then be simply a
triply twisted figure-eight loop just
like this one
so this nothing new it just belongs to
that one
searching further for that fourth client
bottle I came up with this wonderful
contraption I thought this was really
cool because it's sort of like this
thing only there's of two of them I call
this the inverted sock Klein bottle
because at the end the mouth looks like
the part of an inverted sock and this is
like the inverted double sock and I
thought surely that this is different
and this must be you know the new Klein
bottle well to make a long story short
it isn't the main reason actually turned
out that this is not its own mirror
image if I make a mirror image um then
it is clearly different and if you
analyze this and cut it apart in smoky
strips you find out it's falling apart
into two identical mobius strips
okay and so again we have the same
situation we get essentially a like
right hand left-handed version so the
logic says if this verse something new I
get not just one new thing I get two new
things a right hand left handed version
but that paper clearly proves they're
only for client bottles not five so this
must be something known and since it
fell apart into two identical Mobius
bands it really is in disguise that same
thing object again so that was not it
then I came across this one this is
indeed another special client bottle
it's due to Lawson who proved that this
is the minimum energy Klein bottle in
some sense nature would prefer that it's
like a soap film soap films try to take
on the shape that minimizes the surface
area minimizes the built in energy
that's in in the surface and so if
similarly we were to look at this
surface and there is bending energy
required to bend it and the more you
bend it the more energy you require
typically the bending energy of a thin
sheet of metal goes with the square of
curvature and so if you integrate square
of curvature over this surface and
compared this any other Klein bottle
then this one has the lowest possible
energy I thought that is pretty cool
maybe that is number four but again you
can obviously tell by looking at it that
this thing seems to have some chirality
again so it's not its own mirror image
so again if this ver knew there would be
two of them you analyze how it breaks
apart in globus bands and you find it
breaks apart into identical nobody
spends so again we're back on that same
heap okay nothing new yet okay sure
ah now here's an interesting shape it
looks like a special Klein bottled has
two inverted soccer mouths okay that
looks like a roller coaster or something
that should be a d-pad looks a fantastic
right now it turns out it's not even a
Klein bottle because here is what
happens if you start here on the outside
and you go around and you get to the
inside at this mouse
and you go around the inside of the
handle inside of the handle inside of
the handle and you're coming out here
and you're back very over this actually
is two-sided you could clearly you know
paint it with one color on one side and
this the other so it's just a Taurus
it's a weird Taurus you know that kind
of self intersects and does weird things
it's not a client bottle so you have to
be very careful when you look at these
things to make sure whether you have a
client bottle or whether it's actually a
two sided surface sometimes that's not
the recipe that works quite simply but
if you have an even number of these kind
of surface inversion mouth then it's
just a Taurus if you have an odd number
then it's very likely a client bottle so
what is this this a client bottle as a
monster it's a Klein model I call it a
knotted Klein bottle so I can see we
have three times the kind of Mouse that
we find out the ordinary Klein bottle
and it's just kind of hooked together in
such a way that it forms also a trifle
knot and so a knotted Klein bottle I
call a Klein model and it's a perfectly
good Klein bottle is it the magic one no
it turns out this now brings us back to
the ordinary Klein bottle so it belongs
essentially to that shape as a matter of
fact it's very hard to show that number
four because it really relies on the
fact that you need some coloring and you
need to distinguish the longitudinal
edges from the the cross side edges in
the end it turned out to be rather
almost disappointingly simple if you
take this Klein bottle right we know we
could split it in the symmetry plane and
make two mobius bands one half might be
green the other one would be red one is
right oriented or right twisting the
other one is left twisted all you have
to do is switch colors okay now if you
switch colors on the two mobius bands
you get a client bottle that basically
seems to have the color reversed and
there's no way to deform it back into
the other one because they're
right-handed
rathe banned cannot be turned into
right-handed Greenbank but you
essentially need colors to find that
fourth client bottle so finally that was
the answer and it's all in the paper I
didn't invent it I just made it
essentially visible to people and so
that was my contribution there I
actually had it peer-reviewed by those
mathematicians who wrote the original
paper and they loved it they felt yeah I
did
fair description of what they did when
absolutely it was needed to make a more
visible model to have a broader segment
of the pop population actually
understand this right and so I may have
taken hear from one in 10,000 to one in
and the hundred or whatever but that
that's still an improvement
Pulliam kind of cutting through and I'm
rotating my knife
all the way around and then doing it on
the other side the tonot will still fall
apart into two individual pieces